the goal of space X has always been to
make humanity an interplanetary species
and they're making great progress right
although SpaceX has made more progress
than practically all government space
agencies combined unless Elon can figure
out a way to speed up our rate of
innovation he's definitely going to be
dead by the time we get to Mars so I'm
just like would like to not be dead
wearing by the time we go to Mars here
and one of the biggest things standing
in the way of SpaceX right now is money
right now their entire business model is
centered around launching payloads into
space whether that be satellites or
resupply missions to the International
Space Station the problem with that is
that there are only so many people
around the world that want to send stuff
up into space but the revenue potential
of launching rocket launching satellites
Soviet space station why not that's you
know 10 taps out around three billion
dollars a year which is a lot of money
but it's a far cry from Ellen's
estimated a hundred billion dollars to
ten trillion dollars that's needed to
build an all-out city on Mars so even
needs some kind of cash cow some kind of
side business that integrates with what
SpaceX is already doing that doesn't
necessarily align with getting to Mars
but will provide the kind of money
needed to fund their main goal enter
third world internet an untapped
industry that Elon estimates could bring
in roughly thirty to fifty billion
dollars in revenue per year potentially
more than doubled that of NASA's annual
budget something that if he's successful
cannot only speed up the rate of
innovation to get to Mars but might also
inadvertently spark the next internet
Gold Rush
[Music]
this video was sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 people who click the link
in the video description we get to three
months of scotia premium with access to
over 25,000 classes and business
ownership and tech make the most off all
your newfound free time with the link
below in mid 2019 a SpaceX Falcon 9
rocket launched off carrying 16 mini
satellites and there is that live view
so you can see on your screen the
satellites are slowly separating or
separating away from the second stage
and over the next few weeks they will
distance themselves from each other and
eventually use their onboard ion
thrusters to make their way to their
final orbits a little later on the
ground this is what people saw
[Music]
these are the first 60 satellites that
are a part of their plan for a mega
constellation of 1,800 satellites all in
low-earth orbit beaming down high-speed
Internet to the people that needed the
most
the internet is already one of the most
impactful inventions of all time
transforming every single aspect of our
modern-day lives but not for the other
half of the world by 2018 half of
humanity's population around 3.4 billion
people at the time still have not
experienced the Golden Age of
information these 3.4 billion people are
Ilan's customers they are in the
untapped goldmine of opportunity that no
one has been able to reach thus far the
majority of these people live in less
than developed areas where a lot of the
time they don't have access to basic
infrastructure
not to mention digital infrastructure
and current telecom companies probably
aren't going to be doing much about it
being that the current approach of
tunneling wires in the ground or using
slow high Earth orbit satellites is far
too expensive for it to make any
business sense whatsoever and unless
someone try something new it could
possibly take generations for the other
half of the population to experience all
the benefits of being online
that is where Starlin comes in since
there would be 1,800 satellites orbiting
the skies wherever you are in the world
as long as you have starlings pizza-box
receiver plugged in and pointed to the
sky you'll have internet access that's
fast enough to even play competitive
video games no tunneling wires no
worrying about existing infrastructure
on the ground the only qualification
someone needs to be able to access
Internet is if they live on the planet
and the way this works in a nutshell is
if you're in the US trying to connect to
something over the Internet and let's
say China your star link receiver on the
ground will connect to the nearest
satellite orbiting above you that
satellite would then shoot a laser to
the next closest satellite in the
direction of China and it will continue
this game of connecting the dots until
it reaches the closest satellite
orbiting above the area in China that
you're trying to connect to that
satellite will then transmit your data
to the ground and then boom you just
sent data over the Internet via a bunch
of mini satellites and if the connection
in China would like to send data back to
you the data will follow a similar path
connecting the dots through the array of
satellites until it reaches back to you
since the salads are moving pretty
quickly if they get out of range while
trying to establish your connection it
will switch to the next satellite
orbiting in the array the benefits of
this compared to something like
traditional style light internet from
current telecom companies is that their
satellites are a lot bigger and orbit
way higher than StarLink satellites this
not only makes it too expensive to
deploy a large number of satellites but
since it's so high above the ground the
time it takes to transmit data to and
from the ground takes way too long which
equates to a theory a ting ly slow
internet so Starling is kind of taking
the best of both worlds the speed up on
the ground internet and the flexibility
to reach far-off places that comes with
sound like internet and with this system
alone Starling could single-handedly
bring in half of the world into the
modern economy at first StarLink as
estimated to cost around $80 per month
plus around a hundred to three hundred
dollars for the receiver which is
definitely still too expensive for
people in less than developed nations
that's why StarLink will be taking a
familiar approach similar to what Tesla
did in the early days targeting a more
affluent demographic first
if you are a telecom company where are
you gonna invest your money to provide
internet far-off areas where there's
less people per square mile or densely
populated cities obviously cities
because for the same amount of money you
get way more money back and return and
that's why less than developed nations
aren't the only ones starving for fast
internet people that live away from
major metropolitan areas can afford fast
internet but they're the hardest ones
for telecom companies to reach and much
like how the first Tesla Roadster
targeted the wealthy first before
eventually getting to the affordable
model 3 before StarLink is able to serve
the ones that need internet the most it
has to not go bankrupt so you're
focusing on making it work first not
bankrupt right I'm not gonna we're just
wanting to be a need not bankrupt
category that's our goal and that means
starting with customers that can afford
it and then scaling down the cost as
they go and with the FCC already
approving StarLink for a total of 12,000
satellites on top of the current goal of
1,800 slowly but surely the rest of
humanity will be brought online
[Music]
StarLink is in a good position right now
at the time of recording this video they
just launched on number 60 satellites
into orbit just a few days ago bringing
the current total to 360 salads the
satellites are being produced at a rate
now faster than we can launch them and
the cost of the satellite has dropped
below the cost of transporting it to
orbit and the cost that satellite will
keep coming down as we ramp up race and
make design improvements and that's the
biggest bottleneck they're running into
right now trying to launch more of them
into orbit at the same time to bring
down the transport cost at their current
rate of around one Starling launch per
month it will take them around another
two years to get all 1,800 into orbit
Elon is hoping that they'll be able to
solve that problem as soon as their next
generation rocket starship is up and
running but that doesn't mean you have
to wait until all 1,800 come online
before potentially using StarLink as
your internet provider as they'll start
offering service to the northern US and
Canada by late 2020 and as more salads
come online the more customers they'll
be able to service with the goal of near
global coverage of the populated world
by early 2021 by 1997 only a computer
went from afar of luxury to a necessity
an age of information was born with
plenty of money to follow and I protect
a Starling is successful when the rest
of the world starts getting online not
only will even be able to get to Mars
faster but he will have inadvertently
created a similar boom a second internet
Gold Rush if you will think about it
they'll be 3.75 billion more people with
money to spend online double the amount
of eyeballs to serve ads to double the
amount of people who want an online
education double the amount of eyeballs
to watch videos on YouTube 3.75 billion
more people that would need specialized
startups that cater to their unique
needs as they transition deeper into the
modern economy basically whatever
products and services are available
online today they'll be practically
double the amount of people that could
potentially use your service and this
new demographic will have plenty of new
problems for entrepreneurs to solve or
in other words there's probably going to
be a lot more new money to be made but
here's the thing all these future
opportunities coming up the next
potential internet Gold Rush are the
business opportunities that comes with
going to space and Mars will simply
escape our fingers if we don't
dramatically improve our rate of
innovation and to improve your rate of
innovation you need to start building up
your repertoire of skills and knowledge
and a great place to start doing that is
with skill share the first 500 people
click the link in the description we get
to three months of skill share premium
and what all this newfound free time you
have wink-wink you can take advantage of
this great online learning community
where for less than $10 a month you get
access to over 25,000 classes from
experts and creators to gain the
knowledge you need to profit from all
these new opportunities coming in which
includes classes on business
entrepreneurship technology engineering
and a lot more without self education
Elon Musk would not be where he is today
Ilan's entire empire is built on self
education he started building rockets by
reading text books on the subject on his
own time and that's why I love sponsors
like Skillshare they support channels
like this that promote self education
and they make learning on your own so
foolproof so be a part of the first 500
to claim your two free months below and
support the brands to help make this
channel possible
welcome to the watch data n club and if
you've made it this far you might as
well just smash that subscribe button
below because I make video essays like
this on the most provocative stuff in
the world of business every single week
just for you guys and it's free so click
that red subscribe button turn the
notification bill due if you want to
support this channel financially check
out Skillshare these sponsors really do
help make this channel possible you can
follow me on instagram on jake trend io
if you made it this far in the video you
are black my true supporters so thank
you so much you've been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]